On app launch, I know that
you're probably tired of seeing
the dummy data and needing to hit
the refresh button
for real data every single time.
I'm going to show you how to display
the data using the current settings
each time the activity is loaded.
In forecast fragment,
we just refactored the code
so that when the refresh button
is selected,
we call this helper method,
updateWeather.
Now that it's in a helper method,
we can also call it
from the onStart method.
We over write onStart so that
the refresh happens
whenever the fragment starts.
This will cause
the weather data to appear.
We'll learn all about onStart,
and the rest of the Android
life cycle in the next lesson.
At this point, we can also remove
all the fake data that we had
in the onCreateView method.
Then we pass in an empty array list
to the ArrayAdapter.
Now we can test this.
We need to make sure that
this is the first app launch
and that it wasn't already running,
so if it's already running, kill it.
Then tap to open the app,
and then you should see
the actual weather data immediately.
Under settings we can change the location
to be the pairs postal code.
We hit OK, and then return
to the main list,
and then we see that
the weather data has updated.